I'm going to be teaching this spring my
most common course which is over in
earth sciences but i think it's
cross-list in engineering still in the
School of Medicine which is
biomineralization which is how organisms
manipulate crystal formation so if you
really interest in a lot of detail that
would be a course to look at but what I
want to talk about today is what a lot
of people think is the only definitive
way to address climate change you guys
are probably all aware that recently
we've learned that some of the non co2
gases can be mitigated like the hfcs and
other gases and china just agree to join
the Montreal Protocol which is on these
short-lived pollutants and we've learned
that you know that that's going to be a
huge benefit to climate change by
controlling these short-lived pollutants
and we're you're not aware of it but
over the your lifetimes you know
refrigerators and air conditioners have
changed the types of chemicals that are
used in there and getting in the
atmosphere which are very powerful
greenhouse gases and the montreal
protocol has been one of the most
successful legislations and that's going
to certainly help things out a lot but
we still lose still lose the whole
climate battle unless we do something
about co2 and and you know the reality
is that coal is going to be the
principal fuel for electricity for our
lifetimes even if we tried to go to 100%
renewable as fast as we possibly could
we'd still have to burn coal for at
least 50 years to get there and that's
the harsh reality of the situation and
with half of the population of India
being under the age of 14 and what's
happening in China and coal reserves for
our lifetime Cole will be the main thing
powering a luck
cars and unless we address those sorts
of emissions in a real definitive way we
lose we exceed the two degrees and other
things begin to happen so the one single
most important thing if we're really
serious about doing something about
climate change is to mitigate co2
emissions primarily from electrical
power generation and so I'm going to
talk a little bit about how nature has
dealt with carbon dioxide historically
because something a lot of people don't
appreciate about carbon dioxide is the
scale of the issue when we look at the
Clean Air Act and we look at other
pollutants like so2 for example it was
very well handled by the Clean Air Act
Clean Air Act goes back to the legal
principle that pollutant polluters
should pay for their pollution and you
know it was implemented in the 60s and
70s and if you take a pollutant like so2
it was very well addressed by the sort
of cap and trade ideas in the Clean Air
Act and we've done a great job
mitigating so2 but there's still a lot
of work to do in that area folks have
tried to apply the same idea to co2 in
fact the EPA is currently making rules
for regulation to regulate co2 but if
you go to the exhaust stream of a
coal-fired power plant it might be
twelve to fifteen percent co2 the amount
of so2 is a fraction of a percent and so
putting a sulfate scrubber Nesso to
scrubber on a coal plant and charging
the polluter for that amount of so2 is a
really feasible thing to do but trying
to charge for all the co2
being emitted would require more money
than the exists in the world almost for
example we think that humans are putting
something like 30 billion tons of co2
into the atmosphere today and we think
that if we could mitigate just about 10
billion tons of co2 that would make a
substantial change in terms of getting
to that two degree warming you know when
we were at the copenhagen climate
Accords in 2009 the the idea was the
developing world would need a hundred
dollars a ton to not emit co2 to the
atmosphere paid for by the developed
world well 10 billion times a hundred
dollars is a trillion dollars so that
would have the developing world paying
the developed world paying the
developing world a trillion dollars a
year not to pollute and those are broad
numbers and I'm not even sure that's
feasible but there just isn't that much
money so creating a mechanism a
sustainable economic mechanism aside
from even getting to the technical
challenges to induce people not to
pollute not to put c/o tune of the
atmosphere isn't feasible it doesn't
pencil it's not even remotely doable and
so we have to think more broadly if
we're really serious about doing
something about how to make mitigation
large-scale mitigation of co2
sustainable we can't just outlaw all
coal-fired power plants because the
Chinese aren't going to do it the
Indians aren't going to do it and
frankly art Congress isn't going to do
it so and even if we did these lights
wouldn't be on a lot of the power in
California actually comes across the
state border from coal-fired power
plants and when all the venture
capitalists drive up and down sand hill
road in their Tesla's that say this is
clean car well they're burning coal to
power those cars so where is all the
carbon on earth anyway
well in the atmosphere there are about
400 million five hundred million billion
tons of co2 in Earth's atmosphere let me
repeat that there are 400 or 500 billion
tons in Earth's atmosphere of co2 in the
whole hydrosphere the oceans the rivers
the lakes there's a few thousand billion
tons in the whole biosphere there's a
few thousand billion tons of carbon but
in the in the lithosphere of the earth
there's about 70 million billion tons of
carbon in the form of limestone in
almost all the limestone is the fossil
remains of ancient marine organisms and
if you understand that there's another
class I've taught here called carbonates
sedimentology which is how limestone
forms so if we look at something like
the white cliffs of Dover that's about
10 billion tons of carbon that was
trapped about 100 million years ago and
it's still there the pyramids are built
out of limestone very stable material
it's it's a process like this coral up
here making something which turns into
limestone so that that's historically
meaning over the history of the earth
where all the carbons gone it's gone
into limestone now if we look at what we
think about the past and what we think
co2 levels have been in the past going
from about 500 million years ago to 400
300 200 100 here where the white cliffs
of Dover were formed up to the present
right now we're talking about co2 just
having passed 400 ppm and it's been sort
of in the 300s for most of our lives now
it's a bit Manalo we're seeing it past
well these these curves are all over the
place but they do seem to agree that co2
has been different in the history of the
earth and it's been validated these are
from fluid inclusions and many other
very valid methods to look at it and so
if you look at life's a life in the
ocean today most of the taxonomic groups
were extent at least through the
Mesozoic era through very different
levels of co2 partial pressures of co2
and for example we believe it's likely
that when the white cliffs of dover were
formed that means the organisms the
cockle it affords which are these plants
that live in the ocean are responsible
for a lot of the carbon on earth a lot
of the primary production on earth we
believe co2 is about 2000 ppm roughly
five times what it was today and some of
the species talk one of them we're
certain hasn't changed much since a
hundred thousand years ago so the way we
think about carbon dioxide as a
pollutant that can be regulated may not
be just might not be the right way to
look at it because it's actually
probably the most abundant raw material
on earth in its it's what trees are made
out of its what coral reefs are made out
of that that's the primary raw material
and if we change our philosophy a little
bit about how we look at it it might
give us other solutions for our problems
so when we look at the the most
extensive calcium carbonate deposits the
limestone deposits on earth they formed
like I was saying when co2 is much
higher and today of course there weren't
any polar icecap
the world was a lot warmer sea level was
a lot higher plants were going crazy
because plants like co2 you know in
Holland they pump co2 into the
greenhouses so the tulips will grow
faster turns out coral reefs love co2
also because corals have plants in their
tissue it's that are important part of
the mineralization process so if our
whole view of just taking it off is
another pollutant like no.2 no.3 and O
CO and all that so2 probably isn't the
right fundamental philosophical way to
look at co2 it's just another pollutant
that needs regulation so at the same
time the white cliffs of Dover were
forming they were massive the most
massive the most extensive reefs that
ever form on the planet forming now this
is a modern try doc net clam you know
the classic man-eating clam but I show
this photo to show you that the tissue
is very deep color that's because it's
full of plants that are photosynth it's
a mollusk it's a clam it's full out full
of plants and here's here's a similar
organism called the rudest did clam in
these four massive calcium carbonate
reefs all over the world around the
tropical area so a lot of the middle
east erie and jireh mexico a lot of
these massive limestone deposits that
are known are formed by these guys which
actually out competed modern-day corals
on the reefs at that time for various
reasons and we see these all over the
planet so at least in the history of
Earth when co2 has gone up the calcium
carbonate forming organisms have
flourished as well as as plants
here's just one experiment this is a
very well-known experimental model it's
a it's a Alyssa for it it's called
emiliani Huxley I and if you ever fly to
europe in the summer time and you see
these massive blooms in the atlantic
ocean of just hundreds of miles of white
that's these guys they have about a
12-hour life cycle and they form these
discs of calcium carbonate and they have
chloroplasts there you know
photosynthesizing and so this was an
experiment published in Nature a couple
years back it's received a lot of
attention they took emiliana Huxley I
and they varied the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere over the sea water in which
it was living and then asked the
question how did that affect the
calcification of these individual kaka
lifts which is if you went to the White
Cliffs of Dover it's almost one hundred
percent these guys that's what makes up
those white cliffs like chalky white
cliffs and what they found is if you go
to modern-day co2 levels and you look at
the actual volume and they looked at
mass they looked at a lot of things and
then change it to where we think earth's
going they actually calcify more and now
we're seeing this in a whole variety of
groups that were extent that they have
the genetic heritage in their genome to
have lived through the Eocene thermal
maximum number of things the reason
everything is dying not everything is
happening so fast right now but the
point I'm trying to make is that if we
look look at co2 as a raw material as
opposed to a pollutant that can only be
eradicated and thrown in landfills
aren't landfills big enough to put all
the co2 by the way then our whole
philosophy about how to how to mitigate
it
changes a lot so people came along and
said well your experiments probably
invalid there's probably something about
your methodology that made these
calculus respond in the wrong way so the
researchers said okay fine let's go
backward in time and let's go check this
sediments over the last couple hundred
years in fact going back in time they
found that we believe in the pre
industrial area era pco2 was on the
order of 270 290 and in fact as you go
back they get smaller so there's a lot
of work around this area but the point
is if we open up our minds a little bit
to think about how how to think about
this problem we can change the way we
come up with answers for it so how big
is the problem well you know humans are
putting out about 30 billion tons of co2
about 10 of it comes from electrical
power generation mostly from coal plants
another six or so comes from industrial
plants mainly cement plants but other
plans and these are point sources these
are locations where you can actually go
and trap the co2 we can't do that with
cars cars are just tailpipes and we
don't know how to capture all the
emissions coming from cars and so I mean
one positive thing about electrification
is even if you generated the power by
burning coal if you could capture all
that co2 transmit it out to power
electric cars you'd be taking most of
the co2 from transportation which would
be phenomenal so the concept though is
we do lose the battle if we don't
address this no matter how good the
Montreal Protocol is no matter what we
do with energy efficiency we still lose
the battle unless we deal with this it's
like I was just in Washington the week
before last and one of the authors of
the Montreal Protocol who's living these
short-lived pollutants said Brent unless
you do this we lose the battle so let's
just you know point out that Cole isn't
going anywhere the coal production
around the world is substantially
increasing its not decreasing you know I
mean there are laws in California and a
few other places that are trying to
mitigate coal but when i look at my I
live in Portola Valley when I look at my
PG&E bill it says where the emission
sources are and then it has a 21-percent
other which means it's out of state coal
plants bringing power into California
and they don't want to call it out on
your you know it's for it doesn't look
good if we look at the different ways
that electric power and if any of you
had a chance to look at that science
article who thinks that we're going to
be building nuclear power plants in
California very soon what do they call
for like 30 or 40 nuclear power plants
to meet our carbon goal you know in case
you didn't know that two nuclear power
plants in the state of California aren't
operating right now San Onofre is
probably never going to operate again
and if Diablo Canyon ever gets running
again it isn't going to be any time soon
you can be a hundred percent certain
there's no way ever another nuclear
power plant is ever going to get
permitted in the state of California at
least in my lifetime but no matter what
we do we're going to be burning coal and
right now there's a role before the EPA
that says any emission for electricity
for new power generation is going to
have to be below 1,150 pounds per
megawatt which virtually eliminates coal
but what will happen is when they
realize there won't be electricity to
the hospital going and the guy in the
respirator the Independent System
Operator network that's responsible for
grid stability will just step in and the
regulation won't be able to be enforced
so when we look at the vast disparity
between what governments think they're
doing what special interest groups think
they're supporting in the reality of the
situation it's so great it makes you
sort of wonder what we're all thinking
about but that this is the scenario in
the reading from California so with
energy efficiency we're going to get
that blue edge with electricity d
carbonation and they talk about ccs
meaning we're going to separate co2 and
injected in the ground which is proven
to be completely unfeasible even though
governments are putting billions of
dollars into it over the last seven or
eight years it's absolutely never going
to happen smart growth so PV roofing
biofuels non-energy co2 which means
making cement in electrification we're
hoping to meet our goal in California by
2050 but I think if you read the article
the author's say they don't think it's
possible even with this detailed
analysis so you know in my generation we
grew up thinking there was going to be a
nuclear war and we had duck and cover
girls drills where we'd sit under the
desk and things like that but no one
really had the ability to deal with
nuclear war it was it was so intangible
what could anyone do about it and that's
sort of how governments are dealing with
climate change right now there's a lot
of measures to address climate change
but none of them pencil out not even
close
so if we look at something like cement
cements the third largest source of
anthropogenic co2 and it's the cementing
component of concrete and concrete is
the most used building material by far
it's more than fifty percent of all
buildings it it's the most traded
material other than water in the whole
world and for every ton of portland
cement you make you make about a ton of
co2 and put it in the atmosphere and
it's a it really is unavoidable the way
you make it is u-kal sign limestone and
it just really releases that co2 that
was trapped when when it was first
captured by the organisms and we see the
same thing with cement production as we
see with coal production so right now in
Asia for example there's a lot of
concrete being poured there's a lot of
coal-fired generation being poured and
co2 is a global long-lived pollutant so
it doesn't matter whether you're burning
it in Asia or in Northern California
we're still going to see the same global
effect well if we get into it in detail
why is it such a problem to just capture
all the co2 even if you could inject it
into the ground well if we look at
what's actually being emitted on if you
go to say an ethanol refinery or most
refineries they're producing 95 to 100
percent carbon dioxide if you go to a
say a cement plant they're producing
more concentrated thirty forty percent
carbon dioxide if you go to a coal-fired
power plant it's ten to fifteen percent
and if you go to a natural gas plant
it's you know four or five percent co2
and so in the blue
is depicting the quantity in the u.s. of
these different co2 sources you can see
most of it's coming from coal and this
is fairly thrown a worldwide basis
depicted in the green is the estimated
cost of separation which also has a
proportional carbon footprint associated
with just separating so for example to
use a conventional process to separate
co2 from coal-fired exhaust it costs
somewhere around fifty to sixty dollars
a ton but it also uses about thirty
percent of the power from the power
plant to do that so we call that a
parasitic load which increases the
carbon intensity of a plant so the
scheme that that when we went into Kyoto
I mean to the Copenhagen Accord it was
companies were going to build scrubbers
there mea processes chilled ammonia and
then we're going to separate all the co2
from coal-fired exhaust we were going to
build pipelines to transport that co2 is
a liquid and then we're going to pay all
companies to inject it into the ground
and there are billions of dollars that
have been spent and they're still being
spent at the Department of Energy and
foreign analogues to study this
methodology even though we've determined
that within ten years we'd run out of
reservoirs potentially but the main
issue is if you already spent fifty
dollars just separating it you still
have to build the pipeline injected in
the ground monitor it get insurance make
sure it doesn't leak out and kill a
thousand people like it did in Lake
nagole in Africa where a big bubble came
out of a lake and down to a whole
village of 2500 people in about five
minutes and you know for American
Electric Power they had the first carbon
sequestration test at their
plant in Tennessee and you know in the
news is a picture of a lady in a
playground with her children in the
power plant in the background saying I
don't want co2 buried in my backyard so
it's just it's it's not a very feasible
methodology so going back to the idea
that co2 can be a raw material and you
can use it that way here's here's the
plan is if they're about 16 billion tons
of co2 a year and we want to do
something different with it how about
storing it in the built environment how
about storing it in all the concrete
it's being poured every year there's
about thirty two billion tons of
concrete being poured every year around
the world and for every ton of co2 which
has a molecular weight of 44 you can
make about two tons of calcium carbonate
material and someone's already paying
for it you don't have to come up with
any new money to pay for so another way
to look at it is we have a problem we're
trying to address where there are 15
billion tons or so 16 billion tons of
co2 being emitted in the atmosphere
every year in on a continuous ongoing
sustainable basis we're using about 15
billion tons of concrete and we're
actually mining about 20 billion tons of
rock to put in the concrete so concrete
is about ten or fifteen percent Portland
cement which is that co2 intensive
binder material and the other eighty
percent or so of concrete is sand and
pebbles and rocks and aggregate and
the point the main point about it is not
only is this technically feasible and
it's already been demonstrated and I'll
show you but it's economically feasible
and sustainable there's already money
there for example when you go to fill up
your car with gas you might notice
there's I think at eight point seven
percent sent federal tax on the gasoline
you pump into your car if that money
goes to the Department of Transportation
in Washington DC it's a lot of money and
the way they manage it is then they dole
out the money to the states so
California Caltrans you know the guys on
in the orange vests on the side of the
road that's our department of
transportation caltrans gets about 11
billion dollars a year from that
gasoline tax you pay and what they do
without money is they improve roads and
they build roads and the way they do it
is they put it out for bid and because
there are no us cement companies anymore
and the concrete producers are owned by
foreign oligopolies from japan and
mexico and switzerland and germany and
ireland france those contracts all go to
foreign companies so most of that money
actually goes to the shareholders of
foreign companies but it's there and we
potentially have the ability to trap
that co2 turn it into building materials
and pay for it with the money we are
already spending
the process I've been working on lately
is a second generation process that
enables us to capture flue gas and go to
both cement and aggregate as well as
provide a carbon-rich fluid that we can
put in concrete and we're already
already commercializing this we make
this a profitable activity both through
making aggregate which can be used in
road base and asphalt which is a huge
amount of material we can also make a
cement replacement and make concrete
using the process and for example this
is this is one of the first carbon
technologies we're launching this takes
co2 turns it into a new liquid form of
carbonate and when we added to concrete
this is the three day seven day and 28
days strength of the concrete we're able
to put significant amounts of co2 into
traditional concrete here's a control
there's a couple of different types of
mixtures some help the acceleration of
setting some help freeze-thaw resistance
the point is they're all about the same
but if you look at seven days you can
see that when we carbonate the concrete
it actually gets strong faster which
actually is very beneficial on the job
side so carbonation of concrete's
already well known because there's co2
in the atmosphere and like the concrete
in this building is already carbonating
naturally and it makes it stronger but
it's it's possible to make these
building materials carbon negative so if
you take a traditional yard of concrete
it has a carbon footprint around 500
pounds of co2 per yard if we
just replace some of the cement and the
sand and the gravel we can make the net
co2 about negative eleven hundred pounds
meaning 1,100 pounds of co2 is captured
turned into mineral and used to make the
concrete if we also consider the
concrete that wasn't formulated and a
doubt on it's actually a net of 1,600
pounds net negative of co2 so it's
possible there is a solution out there
that is of the right size and scale to
do this the other aspect of making your
own rock and aggregate and you know i'll
admit rock and a great is not as sexy as
biotech or computers or men's it's just
rock but turns out it's it's one of the
largest mass materials flows around the
planet and just for information in the
state of california Caltrans is and
divided this state into 26 venues and
ten of them have less than a decade of
aggregate for all their road projects
and that's because you really can't
permit a quarry anymore and we import a
lot of our aggregate from British
Columbia its barge down it's all
limestone by the way so turns out
there's a worldwide aggregate shortage
believe it or not in the Middle East
they actually ship the sand you wouldn't
think so but there's a SAN shortage in
the Middle East they bring the sand in
from Turkey because it doesn't have salt
in it other things so yeah you're
probably aware of sustainable food
thoughts the idea is you buy food that
was grown locally and you're not
transporting it as far well multiply
that times about a thousand times for
aggregate aggregate is very very heavy
in the Caltrans study they found it
there's
the average distance that aggregates
being moved in the state of California
has gone from about 25 miles to almost
50 miles in the last 20 years and so
these are very heavy trucks which are
making the roads wear out faster if you
make the the the aggregate in the cement
and most of the price of these materials
is actually in the transportation if you
make it locally at the power plant when
you combust a ton of coal you make two
and a half tons of carbon dioxide and
with two and a half tons of carbon
dioxide you can make five tends to
submit or five tons of aggregate via the
methodology we use today if you want to
make five tons of a great you have to go
out to an open pit mine and mine it if
you want to make five tons of submit you
have to go to a limestone quarry burn
coal and Cal sign so you know when we
think about mining in the environmental
impact of mining we think about coal
right Cole ripping off the tops of
mountains and that kind of thing how
much coal do you think's mind every year
about five billion times so there's
about thirty two billion tons of rock
mind every year and it's almost all all
the coal money's most of its shaft money
not open pit most of the reasons
mountains are getting tops we're getting
torn off it has nothing to do with coal
it's about rock mining open pit rock
mining so has anyone ever done this
before well yeah it turns out in world
war two there's a group in the army
called the Seabees that we'd go out and
they would get the coral rubble the sand
if you've ever dove on a coral reef
you'll notice in the back reef there's a
lot of the same limestone precursor
material it's the skeletal remains of
corals and clams and other calcifying
organisms and you've ever walked on the
beach in the tropics and you see where a
fresh stream comes out across a white
sand beach it gets hard that's called
beach
raag that's because fresh water makes
the minerals in skeletal materials
unstable and they recrystallize and
cement up hard and that's how limestone
gets formed and they actually took
advantage of this and formed runways all
over the Central Pacific they're still
there I was just one on one in the Cook
Islands a couple months ago in the most
interesting thing to me though is I was
reviewing some of this with George
Shultz who's here at Stanford who had
the energy initiative and he said you
know what I was there I was a 19 year
old marine and I saw these runways being
built and and that's just interesting
because one of his jobs in life is he
was the CEO of Bechtel which is a large
epc firm which has probably poured more
concrete than anybody in the whole world
so he both seen these formed as well as
you know been in that position so the
concept of forming large-scale
structures with limestone basically is
already there and this has been done
significantly in the timeframe of about
two thousand seven to 2010 I built a
about a 45 million dollar carbon
sequestration plan over on monterey bay
next to the largest power plant on the
west coast which is a 2.2 gigawatt plan
and we built a couple of lines from the
two 550 megawatt cogeneration combined
cycle plants over to an old decrepit
refractories facility in made cement
which has been used to widen highway 1
in santa cruz if you've been down there
lately they've widened out the lanes
where highway 17 comes in to highway 1
going south and so the process itself is
something that can be done we've now
developed a second generation
it's even more economical and developed
but if that dot plant we looked at first
going to inner mongolia to put a plan in
and worked with back tell to work out a
lot of the balances there's a there's a
lot of ways to get this going even here
in California the typically pollution
mitigation equipment is paid for through
rate base so if i have a coal-fired
power plant in wyoming and the epa
promulgates a regulation that says I
have to put my so2 levels to a certain
point then I apply to the public
utilities commission for 250 million
dollars or whatever it costs to to put
that in place and when that's approved
then I put that in the the rate base to
pay for it so the capital costs of
building these plants can actually be
integrated right into the the rate base
of normal utilities so it's very
possible so you know there's there's a
way for large-scale sustainable
mitigation of co2 of the scale that can
address most of the problem you know
that will deal with the co2 as well as
criteria pollutants but store it in
aggregate and roads these materials are
also very light so they have a high
albedo and have a lot of other benefits
so you know I wanted to leave enough
time for questions so I was going to
wrap it up if that's all right so I
think I'll wrap it up there
great one is there anything bread hasn't
other you had that slide that showed
like coal to co2 to cement a concrete so
I was wondering when you burn the coal
you get a single amount of energy out
how much of that energy is then put back
in to make the cement yes that's a great
question so when we're talking about
traditional processes we talked about
the parasitic load which is what we'd
call that and the so with the
traditional process is the parasitic
load today is about thirty percent and
it I guess I've seen calculations that
the theoretical best would be about
eighteen or nineteen percent with the
process we're using it's a little less
than ten percent so it's substantially
lower and that's one of the big advances
that we've made in the last three or
four years the the plant we built down
at Moss Landing had varied parasitic
loads depending on what raw materials
were available but they could be as high
as 25 to 40 percent as well so in the
first generation it really didn't
provide a huge advantage over the
traditional methodologies except that if
you consider the offset of the CEO of
the cement you weren't using it brought
it way way down below that because you
know you also were offsetting the co2
that would have been generated by the
cement formation but now what we have
with the second generation we're even
further along and one of the issues
there was if there wasn't a price on co2
it was difficult to make the economics
work and part of being successful would
involve being economically sustainable
and even though there's not a price on
co2 in most parts of the world today
with the new generation of process it
can be economically sustainable even
without a tax
so for example a ton of cement costs
about a hundred dollars a ton of
aggregate can cost between five and
twenty dollars but it can be even eighty
dollars most of the cost of aggregate is
actually in the transportation so how
far you have to transport it it's not
the actual cost of money in the rock and
remember we're saying in that
traditional process it was about fifty
dollars a ton just to separate the co2
before you even made anything so it was
almost impossible to make the economics
work for for making liquid co2 and
injecting of the ground or using my
first generation process of moss landing
but with what we're doing now we can
make it economically sustainable so even
in countries where there isn't a tax or
some sort of tariff for mitigating co2
we can make it a profitable activity
which will induce people to do it
so you're in the black and just getting
enough capital behind it to deploy this
as white in his widespread away as you
can what's what's the prob well the
second generation is just off and
running you know and we've just
developed the first product and actually
I can pass these around this is from the
American concrete Institute this is a
liquid of carbon dioxide which is just
mixed with the current concrete
formulations and reduces the carbon
footprint of the concrete yeah
large-scale applications of this is
there a problem with the amount of
calcium you would need or is there
another image oh you would use in
addition to calcium what yeah I'm
material you're talking about yeah
absolutely so in what I'm passing around
there is no calcium it's just a liquid
it's a liquid admixture it's a brand new
discovery actually one of our PhDs made
it and described it first in 2012 and it
um it's called a liquid condensed phase
it's it's very interesting it turns out
a lot of the carbon in water and in the
ocean is not in the state we thought it
was it and it has to do with new
instrumentation that allows you to
observe this so but ready mix concrete
has lots of calcium in it so there's no
shortage of calcium but when we do make
our own aggregate our own cement we do
need either calcium or magnesium and
it's seawater there's plenty of
magnesium it's an unlimited source turns
out you're probably familiar with what
hard water is you know that water that
clogs your shower if it forms a little
white deposit that's calcium carbonate
this for me and to put in perspective
the ocean has about 400 ppm calcium in
it that water that clogs your showers
sort of two thousand to five thousand
parts per million calcium
but for example at my first generation
company we got a large doee grant about
47 million dollars to build one of these
out in Wyoming hit a two point one
gigawatt and scrub coal plant and so we
hired slumber J which is a basically a
drilling company they have a whole water
services unit to look around and it
turns out hard water is really easy to
come by in in Wyoming for example they
have through is a huge number 300
billion gallons of what's called
produced water they have to get rid of
every year and they mostly injected back
into the ground and there we had wells
that were 50 to 70,000 ppm calcium and
basically anywhere you go you can find
hard really hard water so that would I
had a whole GA is team that would look
at that it's interesting like if you go
to like the state of Mississippi
anywhere where there's limestone in the
subsurface you know it's it's all over
the place but it's an excellent question
because you know just like when you cite
a cement plant the only place you cite
cement plants is on a limestone quarry
so if you don't have limestone you don't
make some it there you know if you're if
you're doing what we want to do you just
you don't do it anywhere where you don't
have access to all the raw materials you
need I'm excited about this first
product though because it uh it's you
need to understand that concrete
industry is very conservative they don't
move fast for obvious reasons they hate
it when bridges fall down and I have
that experience because i had to
orthopedic companies that made bone
cement for orthopedic surgery and
orthopedic surgeons are a lot like
engineers that build structures in
concrete when they have a bad day it's a
really bad day and and so they tend to
be very conservative so as a result they
really only want to adopt incremental
advances you're not looking to change
we sing one day and the beauty of this
is we get a tremendous amount of carbon
into the existing concrete and there's
already 15 billion tons of it being
poured every year anyway and we're not
changing their behavior we're not adding
costs on we're not even using different
specifications for them to adopt it so
you know one of the themes and climate
change is there's a need for speed and
if we're going to get out there quickly
and start trapping co2 and sequestering
in the built environment we need
something to get adopted into the market
quickly with rapid penetration and when
you want to do that with a very
conservative market it better be a very
incremental change not not a total
change of the way they do everything
because they're not going to adopt it I
should say every yard of concrete poured
today worldwide I guarantee you except
for a few exceptions has a material
called fly ash in it which is a
substantial portion of the concrete and
they put fly ash in because it increases
the strength it also lowers the amount
of portland cement you need in the
concrete which is the most expensive
component of the concrete so the process
of moving materials from coal-fired
power plants to concrete ready mix
plants which is where concrete is
delivered from is already in place it's
happening 24-7 everywhere you go around
the world moving a coal combustion
product to concrete ready mix plants for
inclusion in concrete the Bay Bridge mix
design was fifty percent fly ash and all
that flash actually was brought from the
Powder River Basin to California to mix
in
got it so that's closest like particles
the flash is full of mercury and whole
bouquet of interesting things but you
know frankly you don't want to know what
they're doing with the mercury today
that they're getting from mercury
scrubbers you know it's really do you
think of all the places to store all
these pollutants the safest place to
actually put it in the roadway and the
EPA has very strict leaching tests which
we had to perform on the minerals to
show that these materials let's see now
we're talking at lunch about a there's
one group that had an idea that we were
going to mine hundreds of millions of
tons of limestone take it to coal-fired
power plants run the co2 from the power
plants through seawater create carbonic
acid in the seawater then run it over
the limestone to dissolve the limestone
to make bicarbonate and then dump that
in the ocean to get rid of it and solve
the climate problem that way and of
course you know putting all this heavy
metals in the ocean would me aside from
the hundreds of millions at times the
limestone you'd form and all that so
there are a lot of solutions that you
know are all interesting ideas but if
you kind of go through them a little
they don't really pan out
yeah I really showed a graph that had
the your process versus the traditional
one for the aggregates where you had
like the X's over the things in the
green arrows oh yeah it's just look
confused in there you had I don't think
I was interpreting right if you had one
ton of coal going to two tons of co2 2.5
tons to see you if you had two oxygens
on so the molecular weight of carbon is
12 in a molecular weight of co2 is 44 so
yeah when you combust a ton of coal
which is primarily just carbon you get
about two two and half tons of co2 yeah
oh the molecules of tuning out tons of
by weight yeah so by mass if I take a
ton of coal and I learn it and how do
you and that turns into 5 of x where do
you get the materials are turning to the
five tons of the G sub servings okay
sorry about that I kind of went through
that pass there you guys are all experts
that but anyway yeah so micra way two
carbons 12 molecular weight of oxygen is
16 so if you put two oxygens on a carbon
you get 44 if you put another oxygen on
to make it a carbonate you get then
you're up to 60 and then the molecular
way that calcium is 40 so the molecular
weight of calcium carbonate is 100 100
point 0 4 but anyway it's 100 and so and
that's a rough calculation but if you
take a ton of co2 you add an oxygen in a
calcium you know the mass is a hundred
we get the calcium is right because the
cost of moving the calcium substantially
lower than the cost of moving the only
things because you said the main caught
like Paul's factors need stuff around
right yeah so there's the main source of
calcium is through water you know so and
I meant to say a little more that so one
issue around the unit us today is is
what to do with all the produce water
sometimes its wastewater sometimes it's
coming from oil drilling right now
there's a ridiculous amount of water
coming from a process called fracking
where they pressurize it and bust apart
the rocks and then they have to inject
it down and bring it back up and you
have
a huge environmental problem that
doesn't look like it's going away
anytime soon the price of gas is very
low you know the the government doesn't
want to see Cole so there's more gas and
you're going to see more and more
fracking and more and more I mean it's
it's a terrible problem actually you
know I just mentioned i forgot to
mention in the lecture you know one of
the things we've learned through this
process is we don't have a very good
idea how much co2 humans are really
putting into the atmosphere for example
when you bring water up from the ground
you bring anything up from the
subsurface you bring it from pressure to
almost no pressure so for just to give
you some numbers if you take 100 gallons
of water at one atmosphere pressure five
degrees Celsius you can get about a
third of a pound of co2 into that from
the solubility of co2 if you put it
under just 10 bars which is about 150
psi which is about two hundred seventy
foot depth in the subsurface which is
not very deep you can put 15 pounds so
all over the state of California where
we're bring water up from depth it's
almost always saturated with co2 because
there's no photosynthesis it's all
respiration and there we're off gassing
ridiculous amounts of co2 but the water
quality boards don't really take it into
account you know everyone knows when
water comes up at effervesce as well the
reason it looks like your soda bottle is
it's the same thing that's happening
you're I'm corking it and you know the
amount of co2 will bring up from
fracking from oil drilling just from
potable water you know it's probably on
the order of one of those wedges and
this the water board doesn't even want
to know about it because it's so scary
to even think about it
and there's probably other significant
of outlets of co2 that we don't even
account for and you know a lot of a lot
of the problem is a lot of the county's
done by non-scientists a lot of the
modelers are just grasping numbers which
are not very solid numbers and putting
them into models and this is done at a
very high level you know and part of it
is you know when they put together
groups like the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change you know they'll trees
a physicist and a compass and by the
time they get into a model the
fundamental grounding in the science
isn't there and it's it's really
remarkable how unreliable the numbers
like in the paper you read really are in
terms of really really getting arms
around this and understanding
so the fracking and the bringing up the
water and drilling is also releasing a
lot of methane right but that's nothing
that you're addressing in this
particular know and that's true so meh
things like a 20 22 times more powerful
greenhouse gas than co2 and yeah there's
a lot of methane co2 other things being
brought up with all that water and it's
not being monitored state of California
is interesting we're the only state in
the country where you don't have to
report how much water you pumped out of
your well every year because we have
very strong agricultural lobby and you
know so this is the the California Water
Board cannot go out and you know make a
registry of how much water is being
pumped out of the ground every year
there's no way for them to get that
information and you know that's
California you can imagine what it's
like in the rest of the world in terms
of understanding that and so our basic
understandings aren't very good and you
know most of the efforts going on
documenting how bad it is you know
there's there's very little effort going
into how to mitigate it and solve the
problems you know and in the effort
that's going to document it you know
doesn't really pass a rigorous review of
the numbers going into it
ironic sounding if I caught it right at
the beginning of your lecture and that
was that coral reefs thrive with higher
co2 concentrations but the things are
moving so quickly that there in fact
dying is that I get that right yeah I
think we're in the middle of just
beginning to understand what's happening
Steve Palumbi who's the director of
Stanford's Hopkins marine station down
to Monterey is just doing some
fascinating work right now he's working
down in Indonesia and his students are
looking at coral reefs that are
basically dying they're bleaching their
corals it's probably due to high surface
temperatures you know and that typically
happens when the surface water
temperatures get so high herma typic or
reef-building corals have these
symbiotic dinoflagellates in their
tissue so as an telling that their
symbiotic with they photosynthesize they
take in waste products from the animal
they return corporal hydrates and
everybody's happy but when when the
temperature gets really high they'll
jettison there's those aunt Ellie and
they look white because their tissues
clear you just see the white skeleton
underneath and then they often die after
that but they're these subpopulations
where the water is very hot you know
like I mean I don't know if something
like 38 degrees centigrade hot 40
degrees centigrade and they're thriving
whereas the same species 100 yards over
there is it and so they're beginning to
ask some really interesting questions
and one thing they've done is genotype
these corals and they're finding that
the ones that are thriving have four or
five specific genes that the other ones
don't have and these are in taxonomic
groups that were extent back in the
Cretaceous and they lived through the
Eocene thermal maximum 40 million years
ago so you know it's likely that the
genetic heritage
you know the variation to deal with
these changes exists in the current
genome but the chances that would be
able to respond in our lifetime or the
rate at which you know it's increasing
or like zero you know so you know i'm
not saying let's pump alessio to the
atmosphere right i'm not saying that at
all i'm just saying we're learning a lot
more about how to think about co2
because in general it's like investing
in the stock market you know general
they say if you were in the stock market
you're going to make money over time but
it goes down real fast enough and all
that in general over the history of life
increased co2 appears to have improved
reef-building you know improves the
marine phytoplankton that are calcify
hers and how to have these kind of
effects I mean but if you think about
drastic measures to save a reef like
take the Mesoamerican Reef off Belize
there are hundreds of miles literally of
dead Elkhorn coral and it's really sad
but if you're swimming along every
hundred yards or so you'll find one
that's really happy and you think well
what was different about this one and
you know someone was going to take a
drastic measure you'd go genotype that
or you would clone it and you'd
redistribute it you know to try and
reestablish those reeds before they're
taken over by algae and you know you
know and it's complicated you know
there's overfishing there's agricultural
run up and there's there's a whole bunch
of things there's temperature it's a
sickness in application
every roots lecture at the very
beginning of the quarter where you know
and plant animal populations can respond
to changes in conditions but its rapid
changes all in the same direction is
what what's the problem and I think
you're saying given a little slower you
know evolution of what's going on but
that coral reefs could respond but as it
is a few were pretty lucky but to have
that the widespread sorry happening time
my just suits might be the coral reefs
are over you know I did my dissertation
on corals and how they form their
skeletons and compared to the way they
were in the 80s there it's dramatic
although there are few places where
they're still around but if they do
continue to survive we're going to see a
real change in what species in general
actually compose the reef and that's
going to change the whole shape of the
reef you know in the wave resistance
structures and all that kind of thing my
point about bringing it up is just you
know in in the natural world co2 is
thought biggest raw material it's not a
pollute you know if we're biomimetic and
we're going to learn from that we're
going to see it as a raw material and
take advantage of it you know the
largest structure on the planets the
Great Barrier Reef and it's it's all
calcium carbonate formed by calcifying
organisms you know it's been there for a
while
we've got a couple minutes no this is
vertically important thank you for
sharing it with the class I mean this
just gives me one more ray of hope out
there what you're doing thanks a lot
you